a beautiful statue she said he's gonna
have three statues R that's that's that
that's G to be a great joy to see and
listen I have a have a million Kobe
stories and I'm glad I had the
opportunity to play with him uh
definitely wouldn't have got three in
the row without him defish Big Shot Bob
Phil Jackson I don't call him PJ philon
I asked I asked you Tex winners the city
of of Los Angeles but you know out of
out of all the stuff we we went through
his family was very nice to me so again
I want to shout out his mom Pam his
father Joe sister sha and Bria all again
I don't get talk talked about a lot so I
just want to show my love and respect to
them but listen this day is is bound to
happen I'm glad to be part of the most
enigmatic controversial dominant onew
punch ever created never to be
duplicated uh when you you say Kobe you
say Shaq when you say Shaq you say Kobe
and if I had one wish I wish we would be
talking to him right now so uh
congratulations to him and his family
especially his mom and his dad and his
two sisters I want to say
congratulations to the Lakers
organization uh and he did it and you
know who else I got to thank Jerry West
because Jerry West put this thing
together lot of people don't talk about
it like if I don't if I don't go
there he don't trade vat and it's a
possibility he don't even get copy so Mr
West wherever you are thank you for
helping me win my first three
championships you don't get mentioned a
lot either but you put this thing
together sir and I remember when you
called me in first and you had me look
up at the routers and say Shaq I know
you're doing movies and you're doing rap
but if you do this thing correctly your
name will be up there can I ask question
hold on my name's up there my statue is
in the front Kobe's name up there twice
his statue is in the front a lot of
people on that stage but you did this Mr
West thank you so you know he he told
you I got this guy you've seen a lot of
guys he played with Penny Hardway at
that time what was the day that you
looked and said he is that guy well I
used to test him a lot be like I need 40
he get it I need 50 he get it but before
that before so like listen we all been
in the league and you know a guy could
have one of those but like I'm I'm I'm
I'm testing them an E40 he get it I need
50 he get it you know we would always
get swept I think we're probably the
biggest stars that got swept the most I
think it's four or five but once we got
it the first championship I think it was
the Indiana game I want to show show his
footage if you have it he sprains his
ankle and then I kind of take over game
I carry him out on my back and then I'm
thinking the next game with two games
over I file out right and it's like four
or five minutes and he looks and he says
I got it like he know he not even don't
worry about it I got it and he took the
game over like I I've seen him take the
game over before but we need this game
like this like you know we we we got
swept people think we don't like each
other we lose this series we're done he
looked got it Phils call him plays he's
like n no got so then I knew he was and
then it was I think after our our second
Championship he had on the Jordan jersey
and I I knew I had to give it up and I
say player it's time to take that Jersey
off and put your own on now cuz I I knew
then that he was the man this date uh
2824 special obviously for the Lakers
for the Bryant family for the NBA for
the Sports World number two is what Gigi
wore and of course 8 and 24 koby's
[Music]
numbers